Hello, the internet I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys and for this video
we were lucky enough to
be given a car by BMW.
Yeah, cheers BMW.
This is a two series convertible BMW.
So it's pretty nippy.
I mean, I was playing
around with it earlier
and I was getting some, I
was getting pretty fast.
Because this is a convertible
it's been designed in
a very aerodynamic way.
As the car drives, the air
flows over the top of the car.
And hopefully, in the rain,
prevents everyone inside from getting wet.
So for this video, we're going
to be testing exactly that.
We've set up some fake rain
at the end of this road
and Dan's going to drive through it.
Shall I give it the beans?
Full beans.
Full beans?
Yeah.
Did they say anything about
wheel spins or handbrake turns?
They did not.
They didn't?
No.
Excellent.
Woo!
Dan, you absolutely ragged it.
I did give it maximum beans on that, yeah.
What was the experience?
Well I was probably doing
about a 100, 110, maybe.
You got up to 100?
Yeah!
I thought you were doing 60!
No .
Did that look like 60
miles an hour to you?
I was going to say.
You were like, "that was a fast 60".
I almost got run over by the wind.
You said "maximum beans"!
I'm sorry, yeah.
Right, so, yeah.
It's like I'm driving along
and then it's just this wall of water.
I'm like huh .
And it just hits the car
and like a big sudden clap.
And then I'm just like
come out the other side
like, "oh, I'm perfectly dry".
So yeah it's pretty cool
because obviously the rain's coming down
but because of the wind and
because I'm going so fast,
it pushes it over the
back and keeps me dry.
But obviously I'm trying
to keep a cool face
and be like, "yeah, it's fine, no bother".
But then yeah, this slow mode
determined that to be a lie
and I'm like .
Okay, so now Dan, I'm gonna get a shot.
I'm gonna be behind you in the car.
Sweet, I think that'd
be pretty cool actually.
Because that's where I am right now.
Are you gonna get the rain
hit in the front like a wave.
I'm gonna try and get you
and also see if we can
see some of the water coming over.
I want a super wide lens.
It's a 12 millimeter lens
which is why it looks like a bin lid.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Woo!
Whoa!
Jesus!
I can see why you like doing this so much.
That's actually a pretty dam cool shot.
Yeah?
Well Dan, that worked perfectly.
We saw the trail of mist that the car was
just putting straight
over everyone in the car.
Yeah, that was really fun.
I mean, you had three
people in the car there,
no one got drop of water on them.
It's like you just hit a wall of water
and then it's just like .
Yeah.
Oh.
And you were giving it
some good beans there.
Yeah maximum, ultimate beans, big beans.
Well, I hope you enjoyed that video.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter,
buy a t-shirt if you want.
We've got three shirts and
subscribe to the Slow Mo guys.
Cool.
Thanks for watching.
Cheers, oh God!
At this point, it's basically just rags.
Yeah, I'm still not getting you a new one.
Oh man.
You gotta take care of your uniform.
I've got two holes in it!